[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks lucky stars that we have this
baby boy off suspension
yeah I am on parole so I'm gonna keep it
real clean today you guys welcome back
to the break room Our Daily Show that
keeps you updated on all the nerdy news
you need to know about coming up today
uh mandatory fun return what I wonder
why
uh Neymar needs a sequel and Tommy gets
tattooed what there I said it Tommy does
it it's gonna happen to Tommy she's
trying to call the election excuse me
off the count I'm here today with koi
genre oh fancy thanks for that little
little flavor
Jessica Clemens who cares you got Tommy
V who's counting these votes cyber ninja
and ballot
my shirt says Big Sky whiskey which is
ironic because I don't really drink
anymore
no they're gonna say I just don't like
whiskers unless you want to puke oh my
gosh and speaking of puke Brandon Barry
I love whiskey I do too I mean that's
kind of the problem that's why I put it
on my shirt I love whiskey I love it so
much oh baby it's okay
um speaking of which L.A whiskey
Festival Thursday night in uh Pasadena
I'll be there
Thursday night yeah it's on a Thursday
which is just foolish that's crazy it's
also very cold here Christian
unpronounceable says welcome home oh
Christian good to be home in the loving
Embrace of all of you you guys today's
Redemption and honor of literally
absolutely no one being able to get
tickets to Taylor Swift's era's tour
yesterday for every 100 in super chats
that we raise we're gonna give you the
live performance of a lifetime uh Taylor
Swift covers with a no more twist we
call it Taylor's version yeah
parentheses Taylor's version
Taylor's version do you guys have
Insight on how you got these songs uh
actually I this is so funny I was uh I
was on my yacht yesterday as I offered
him and I heard a siren Call
foreign
and I walked off the side of my yacht
wow straight into the ocean was
swallowed by a hot back wow what will
you believe that right through the
baleen I went through the baleen of the
whale straight out of the end of his
dork oh uh and and also out of his dork
I found these two sacred Scrolls
containing Scrolls names Scrolls Scrolls
not Scrolls Scrolls containing lyrics to
Taylor Swift themed Neymar songs uh I I
lied there's actually three of them oh
okay and I gave one of them to my Swifty
from another mifty Brando from my baleen
to my shade I like when you call Brandon
brandor
brandor that's my favorite Marlon
Brandon with an Australian accent yeah
nor brandor
stop you can't keep getting away with
this folks we gotta get right into our
big discussion today uh we all love to
play Panther we're kind of forever yada
yada you've heard it you're sick of
hearing it yeah I haven't got a chance
to talk about another show yet I'm very
excited bursting at the scenes ready to
talk about this but we want to talk
today about what's next for our good boy
the Boy without love no more
uh you know we've already asked what's
next for black panther uh uh Black
Panther shuri you know what's next for
her Jessica's got a video coming out
tomorrow that dives into what's next for
Riri Williams in the MCU you know how
she's going to get from point wakanda to
point ironheart uh but right now we want
to know we want to talk about what's
next for no more after wakanda forever
and not just like the crazy like ooh
what if he gets on an airplane
he's not Doom
he's not too
he's not dude
okay
uh he's not he must be doing this uh but
we're gonna we're gonna dive into like
all the facts that we know some stuff we
can infer from the comics what they're
laying out here this like path forward
for our good buddy no more because we
know he's coming back yeah right they
got to bring him back because I don't
want it done I have a question have we
covered this is he gonna come back with
all four feathers did they grow back or
did she remember I hope they grow back
the root out of that I think you can
heal from like a gunshot yeah you can
heal from a normal bird but what if he
mulch what if what if she tore it out at
the stump you know when you stomp a tree
boy tiny boy make me fly all right sorry
let's focus up all right so so let's
talk about uh uh some of like no More's
like biggest uh friends his allies and
his enemies in the comics which is kind
of the same thing it's two sides of the
same coin because no more around forever
he's a little wrestler he's bought
everybody he's fought alongside
everybody it's really hard to determine
he doesn't have like tried and true like
he's always enemies with this person
it's like thousand-year-old vampires
right like eventually if they are you
know heterosexual vampires they marry a
man for 100 years because they're like I
can't do this with a woman anymore then
maybe they go back to women and maybe
they just become bisexual vampires what
I'm saying is
so yeah that's all I just want to make
that announce I just want to lay that
out make that clear vampires are all bi
because time passes not because of you
know any compulsion inside of them you
know no I don't know I'm learning so
much
oh I missed you uh you want to apologize
no never you didn't do anything wrong I
didn't that's right uh CK in the chat
already pointed out when I asked like is
no more a friend or Foe the answer is
always yes
yes to everything uh because first of
all like in the comics right his biggest
friend slash foe is Black Panther
they're always like buddies they're
always hating each other uh you know
black panther sends a bunch of missiles
to blow up uh Atlantis uh no Neymar
tells Thanos oh there's a there's an
infinity stone in wakanda when there's
not uh and he goes and destroys what
kind of like things like that friendly
things you do with your friends yeah
just friendly it's like when you dox
your friend during the game of cod
because they frag you right my Sims
dab on that uh so so whatever the next
Black Panther movie is uh I bet no more
will be a part of it in some aspect yeah
we'd probably see him there but that's
probably very far out in the future uh
we know we have some like Avengers
movies coming Kang Dynasty Secret Wars
is he a friend of the Avengers yes
question mark again like he works with
them a lot but then he's fought every
single member of The Avengers at some
point uh and usually wins those fights
are like gets thrown back into the ocean
they always fight him in the ocean which
is again a bad idea is it like Brandon
would you say it's fair to say that like
nemour is like the like cool Rebel at
school that doesn't really have any
friends yeah yeah but everybody's
desperate to be his friend even though
he keeps doing bad things and they're
like no but we gotta get him on all
these teams because it's like if you go
to like any comic book Wiki I prefer
fandom sorry guys not a plug just a hug
to a friend of the show uh oh my God uh
he's on every team he's been on every
single team at some point like he is
not monogamous yeah he's gone around
much like a vampire he's been alive in
every way yeah man's making fish moves
yeah uh yeah he's a part of the Avengers
sometimes he's not a part but sometimes
he'll be a part of the Avengers and
something happens in Atlantis he's like
I gotta go guys you're on your own yeah
like no matter what people always go
first yeah yeah yeah
sometimes then of course he was part of
the OG Illuminati right uh which is like
a very more modern thing and so the more
modern we get in the comics the more we
can infer what they're maybe going to do
with these movies they've introduced the
Illuminati of course already in a
different Multiverse makes me think the
616 should probably get one together uh
before it's too late that original
Illuminati was of course Mr Fantastic
Iron Man Doctor Strange Professor X and
Black Bolt uh and then he winds up
leaving that initial group because they
they're the ones that wanted to like
send the Hulk into space for being a bad
boy he was like that's a terrible idea
don't do that and they did it and he's
like I'm out of here yeah I hate you
guys I'm never coming back
um so those are like his friendly foes
now let's talk about his Foley friends
okay the ones who are more often foes
the big one being Dr Doom him and doom
do not get along most of the time they
they do get out a lot they have
competing interests they're all they're
each trying to destroy each other's
secret secret places now one point Doom
does give no more uh a safe Refuge when
he needs it at one point kind of a Tuma
takes over and he's like I gotta get out
of here for a little bit he goes and
lives with doom he uh no more even joins
the cabal at one point which is all is
all bad guys and bad ladies it's Dr Doom
Emma Frost uh Norman Osborne Loki and
even the hood oh we're about to see him
soon right right so he gets along with
the villains too uh gets along with the
good guys gets along passionate
um and like I mentioned before atuma who
we've seen in this film right he's a big
he's a big Foe for no more at some
points because the tomb was like I don't
like how you're running things down here
I'm gonna take over so they kind of duke
it out a lot and considering we had a
tumor in this film we kind of ended on a
weird note with a Tuma and no more like
I could see that becoming a problem for
him in the future I I think we are going
to see like a a kind of a God and style
storyline for no more I think that's
something that could Propel him into the
anti-hero rather than just antagonist
yeah it's like atuma nomura sorry if I'm
stepping on anyone else's thing they
kind of go like this guy sold us out he
quit Against The Economist we could have
killed them all in that big ass boat
that we had blown right from the bottom
we clearly if if nemour had said kill
them like I feel like yeah yeah kids
were like yeah they were they were gonna
they're in the middle of the ocean
they'd kill everybody yeah and except
for people can fly away maybe but uh
it's like but then Neymar would just
chase after him
me with his eye with his fists in his
hands anyway I feel like I feel like
that's where we're headed yeah matuma
and Amora exiling Neymar and he's so
honorable you know even with his devious
deeds in the way the way he's played uh
in Black Panther were kind of forever
that like if his people turned on him he
wouldn't necessarily immediately turn to
Vengeance he'd probably just go and be
like all right well I'm gonna go through
you guys I'm gonna go live with some uh
Neymar more like no more I'm gone
[ __ ] uh damn
yeah we've talked about in the office a
lot like that scene of shuri and him
coming back on the plane being like hi
guys as they're all in the middle of
like standing on each other that's like
that would be like Jesus coming back
with like Satan being like we're cool
put it all down does anyone uh put the
faces of of nemour and shuri over Danny
and Sandy in Greece when they're waving
from that I don't think that convertible
going to heaven if not I've just given
you a great idea put it on top get on a
million views get a sponsorship from one
of those weird vibrator companies
Celtics uh yeah all right watch the cash
flow to your point uh Tommy Edge slice
in the comments point out that phase
four had so much focus on gods for there
not to be a story about a rejected God
especially since nemour is considered to
be a god they really didn't get into I
thought they would get into the
avatarness of no more they didn't really
do that in this like there's no has no
more ever talked with the real cuckoo
con who's out there hanging out I don't
think he's an actual Avatar which is
interesting and it's I I like that not
every religion has there has one yeah
and it's just the Egyptian mythology
they can take avatars but I uh I don't
think he is what boss doesn't have a
term because they said Boston
yeah you know there's Boston
giant Duncan coffee yeah it's been Green
Monster
it's traffic we're gonna make a street
stick like this and then they go like
that and then they go like this Mickey
Ward the god of Boston oh my God
mayamati Walsh see something say
something I'm from Boston but I'm uh
Paul Revere so I still have a bridge of
sex
so that's a good one it's great it's in
perfect 1700s let's go throw rocks at
some people that don't have the same
color skin his ass
let's go Red Socks I ate some clam
chowder and now my ass is exploding okay
north of Tremont 1976. I don't want to
go to Boston regardless of my final
friend slash foe that I want to mention
for no more and then we'll go on to
whatever
is that uh Magneto and no more have an
interesting relationship Comics uh of
course no more being a mutant
Magneto having his Brotherhood of
mutants he's often tried to recruit
sorry I'm thinking about Tommy
ruined me I'm so sorry he's actually
trying to recruit no more to join his
cause like yeah you'd be great you're
immune you're one of the OG mutants well
they're both together like Underdog
anti-heroes well not underdogs but
they're moving yeah they're both like
people that no matter what will be down
for their their folks and Magneto is it
similarly and it seems like the the more
definitely that we're getting in the
movies have a real uh uh attraction
towards like god-like humans right like
they want like Magneto anyone who is
ultra powerful like they he's like he's
so drawn to them like he could not let
possibly let Mystique stay away yeah
completely seduced her to the dark side
not sexually uh as a as a the real you
yes exactly it made you feel welcome he
made her feel included because he knew
what an incredible power she was there's
a there's a great story in the early
early comics where uh Magneto's trying
to recruit Neymar and he's like hey you
can marry my daughter oh I'm trying to
talk about
there's another great story where like
Neymar's flying around and he flies over
the Savage lands and he just sees like
Magneto laying there next to a volcano
he's like oh my poor baby he takes him
back to Atlantis to like heal him up and
then
uh Magneto just takes over and like he
comes getting like they were sitting on
his throne or Magneto sitting on day
more stories like it's mine now he's
like come on
come on
yeah and then at one point when Magneto
builds that's how it works when he
builds Utopia the island from yeah he's
like he needs to build support
underneath it so he's like hey Mark Come
build some pillars underneath the mat
and they do and they have like a little
kingdom above and a kingdom below
Step Brothers they got a little bunk
beds yeah
let's talk about some of the Neymar's
other motivations Jessica do you think
yeah that he could hide Tyler Khan in
some way if he needed to or he's like a
city with him right he can't take the
city with him
um that's the hard part is like how much
what was the math again you're the
scientist how much of the how much of
the world is water uh it's like 75
didn't seem like it was on the ground
right no kind of floating yeah yeah it
looks like diluted
well we know it was deep enough that the
pressure would simply kill you or you
could wear a suit
always smiles you can still talk I don't
know there's no bubbles and um
those bubbles I think it's gonna be too
hard to relocate with all the people or
even the because I do think it's all
rooted in something but I do I'm hooked
on the fact that he did say like this
city so there might be other cities yeah
Capital City yeah yeah I think there are
more sit you can go to the other cities
but again I think eventually everyone's
gonna know that it exists because
Atlantis which we know it's not but did
like how you work got out it was it kind
of got out uh Atlantis has fought the
Athens uh and came out of the water and
tried to kill everyone in Athens they
helped during World War II so it was
like oh okay clearly these people exist
he even fought in New York and he fought
Johnny Storm and uh then he fell in love
with
his sister fire and water more on that
later as well so it was like it's like
as soon as he comes out of the water
people are like oh there's this fly man
where he come from he came from the
bottom of the sea but also when they
were trying to release set a tumor was
in charge of everyone this is when uh
like how you said no more left his right
he left the actual Kingdom and was like
oh he can also exiled a lot of times and
atuma would take control and the tumor
was like we're all gonna leave this
place right now as Warriors and defeat
people on the surface so people knew
they existed and I think translated to
the MCU that will happen once they have
to come above water to fight everyone
everyone's gonna be like oh these people
came from the bottom of the depths of
the ocean let's go check out what's down
there I think it's gonna parallel
wakanda right like we're gonna see that
once wakanda Genie out of the model we
know you exist we know you're in a
formal country remember it wasn't that
long ago in the MCU they were like oh
they've got a bunch of goats like
whatever that line was from Ross and
then he tried to defend it I think what
now that we've seen Namor in any
capacity we're gonna start to try to
find it and that might be a storyline of
how he becomes the god again I mean we
already kind of sorry I keep hating it's
okay so I think don't leave I think it
is uh we also talked about it in Black
Panther wakanda forever remember when
Nakia was talking to her and they were
like everyone knew the legend of the
feather serpent God that was like on the
coast of the water
oh he's floating so it's like okay so
people already know this man exists and
he comes from the depths of the ocean
even if it is a myth it's like we we've
seen it and the Kia was able to find
this woman that was like hey you've
talked about this guy it's a little too
easy I was like when she was able to be
like Google they're like it's a myth she
was like okay I'm gonna go to the edge
of the water and there's the entire land
there's where they settle hey uh this is
a water edge you said Water Edge is on
one Water Edge right right there's there
it is there's the thing yeah they should
have walked down the coast a little bit
at least a little bit they take those
little skinny boys the Jets the waters
they pointed and was like you can just
look in this area yeah it's like using a
metal detector yeah but I was like oh
okay so I think it's really easy for it
to get out is what I'm saying right yeah
they're definitely going to be looking
now I mean they have the home home team
advantage of like come down here and
fight us because that's the hardest
thing right yeah even in our reality
we've explored like the moon more than
we've explored like the bottom of the
ocean like it's so hard to get down
there it's dark as hell
yeah yeah you have to have these
pressure things eventually I feel like
Captain Marvel will be the one that has
to shoved down there and then she's like
flew through it it's very Advanced don't
really want to go back he does do that
in the comics like she'll just be down
there fighting like even without a mask
on yeah you can just go down there like
Iron Man and Thor and stuff we'll just
and even the Hulk can go underwater
because his body just makes oxygen when
he needs it uh even though sometimes he
passes out the comics are weird it's not
naughty you got writers you got
everything that's when everyone can play
when people are like the Hulk is Nerf to
the comics or in the MCU he's nerved in
the comics constantly yeah he's he's
either like a world breaker or like he
hits his head and he's like and like
turns and like Mr Fix It like you got
different personalities that have
different Power sets too but his
physiology wouldn't change only his
mentality would change is it his mental
controlling his physical his physical
controlling his mental that's what I
hope we get into it what is it
do you think because as we were saying
like when he comes back from that fight
with shuri and they're like buddies and
everyone's like hi we're in the middle
of this fight what do you mean you
changed your mind it's very comic book
of him if he gets exiled over right that
would make a lot of things I'm on record
on this show
God in Exile Namor God and Exile that's
a great title for a solo film I disagree
with Tommy I don't want the reason I
don't want him to is because it doesn't
seem believable yet that I I understand
that he was like for all these years I
can keep you safe and then they're
randomly not safe at once I understand
that but it's like how many other times
did he keep you guys safe how many times
did he bring down the sun he built but
they they're not they don't live as long
as he does so but he's got to tell a new
generation of talopians that they have
that he saved them all you know
eventually and I think like all gods the
stories become myth but we or and people
still keep believing
I'm gonna say that I think that someone
invades and then he has to defend them
and that proves his worth again so I
think I think that maybe there's like a
you know trepidation maybe there's a
combo between the two where they're like
oh I don't know if we can trust him
anymore and then he's like I got you and
then that's the movie like if they do a
name or singular movie or if
Thunderbolts which a lot of people are
theorizing like maybe the Thunderbolts
invade and that Neymar proves himself
self because he keeps you know
because I can see the thunderbolt's
going after my brain I could see that as
well perhaps that is the task the
unenviable task and maybe they
themselves much like the suicide squad
realize that their mission is not a
mission of virtue but rather a mission
to hurt you oh my God now that's coming
up but that's not coming up next and I'm
here to talk about where we are going to
see nemour next and I have my pick okay
of where we're going to see them next
but I want to run through some other
possibilities real quick first feel free
to chime in secret Invasion the secret
Invasion Comics Neymar was part of the
Illuminati and ultimately the end was
revealed to be a scroll is there a
chance that the that a scroll could have
caught sight of Neymar and and takes him
on or at least we get the Visage of
nemour uh as a scroll I think I would
love that I would love because I give
more way to like how easy it was people
were like yeah he floats on the edge of
the water a squirrel could just be like
okay noted right sees him and does what
he does but I also like that scroll
would then have to like find a way to
float yeah
if he's a super scroll yeah they could
just copy the physical look and I also
don't know if I I guess they do change
their physiology I don't know if he'd be
able to breathe
well I don't think maybe he's the one
you see him he's like like okay
see a squirrel dip or proposing as a
diplomatic no more and like going into
like the UN or whatever that you know
U.N proxy is in the MCU and being like
hey let's do some business let's get you
down there we can I guess you'd still
need to be
you have to know yeah this smells like I
picked the wrong in the comics there's
like 60 years of continuity that they've
built into it so it's a moment I don't
think that's a moment like hey we just
met this guy well as I said I believe
that there's very low likelihood that we
see him in secret Invasion but as usual
I'm probably wrong so next up we have
Quantum Mania now Ant-Man and Amor where
the final two editions of mad fractions
Defenders run almost a decade ago Neymar
being a reluctant Choice as usual
everybody's like we need them we don't
want them but we need them an Ant-Man
joins they're a river we need the water
guy and joining the final game against
the celestials now we know the battle in
in quantumania seems to be Kang so I
think it's probably getting low
likelihood we're going to see no more
this soon in quantumania I also think
you can take Guardians and Echo off the
table Guardians because it's in space
and Echo because it's in the middle of a
landlocked Bumble F area of the of the
US
hey shout out to Oklahoma what I like to
call the Midwest New Jersey uh I'm just
kidding love you both love both but love
both States you can stop sending me
memes guys I don't really hate New
Jersey I hate Delaware all right now
in ironheart oh sorry I got ahead of
myself okay I believe we can see
telokians and telokian uh imagery in the
Marvels because that mysterious arm that
we all thought was Cree I think it might
be colloquian and that might be what the
Bengal was on so I could see like a
talokian influence but not no more now
iron heart is a strong candidate to have
no more in them uh by the way guys I
wanna before I finish this we are so
close to a first redemption in Super
Chat and if you haven't liked and
subscribed yet you're on my list so
super chat like And subscribe so we can
get to these Tunes ironheart as I said
strong candidate for no more the more
adjacent appearances so this is a bit of
a cop-out but I believe there's going to
be uh like we what we learn from the
more immediately is he does not like
loose threads what is a loose thread
dangling that girl in the Iron Heart
suit the scientist as he calls her who
he wanted dead for 98 of the movie and
then was suddenly like ah fine that's
part of the truth
I don't buy it I think in iron heart we
will get appearances by atuma and nomura
seeking the revenge on behalf of Neymar
uh death to the scientist I think is
what they're going to want not me though
I'm excited for ironheart I think it
would be cool to see them come out of
the Chicago River yeah so because you
have like a river running through the
city on St Patrick's Day when it's dyed
green and they're like green they're
like bluish green they're not like what
is this all right so we can't breathe
next we've got a very nice Super Chat
from David Z says if any of you
addressed the teacher Professor who
asked reread to build the vibranium
finder professors could be doctors well
we may have a little more for that
coming up on the channel tomorrow
tomorrow
all right that we have been thinking
about that we will address it David Z
yes David are you Dr zayas from the
Planet of the Apes films
all right now Agatha House of Harkness
okay a long shot as we had said before
you know Magneto has made unsavory
Overture student and more concerning his
daughter Wanda maximoff in the comics
why don't you marry my daughter Wanda
you can make babies under the sea not me
Daddy I don't want to marry this man but
you must the Submariner must come in the
fold that's my musical marry my daughter
please make my daughter a wife please
it's a work in process it's going I
wired magazine called it I don't think
so bad uh all right so
this Neymar might be pursued by witches
I believe in House of Harkness okay uh
in an attempt to get some of his
vibranium enriched plants and you're
talking about the actual plant here
right yes vibranium enriched you know
what I'm saying no no no they want the
plant for this stuff you know witches
needs let me get some of that they need
plants for their spells and in the
comics Agatha is ancient she knows of
Atlantis before it sank into the sea you
guys listen to me that's actually very
old yeah 15 000 BC I believe and she's
500 years older than that now in the TV
show she seems to be alive since like
six
but that is kind of concurrent with win
the telecon right took the uh the blue
flooring that was that was 1571 yeah yes
oh we've reached uh her stuff happened
in like the 1600s yeah so I don't know
maybe she maybe she was already alive
before then I I just think the timelines
could overlap but I don't think it's
gonna be that here's what's going to
happen Captain America
and the OG cap teamed up to fight the
Nazis as the Invaders named by who
stands in church oh okay well Stanley
through I'm right I'm right it's not
inaccurry who's on the current Invaders
roster Oh Captain America Sam Wilson and
Neymar once again my friend so perhaps
Neymar will need Sam's help or Sam we'll
need no More's help my best guess is the
next time we see Neymar or no more
is in the post-credits scene where Sam
Wilson goes to the beach and goes on a
conch shell finds Neymar and recruits
him for help against a looming big bad
Kang anyone Doom anyone Red Hulk anyone
Contessa Valentina De La Soul anyone
I couldn't remember
to come out of the water with Sam Wilson
and he's like you shrimp killer I will
have your hands
I was friends with those strips you
killed Paul we see the whole scene
and Duke and Franny and Evan and Luke
and Matt the nation it's a very uh
eurocentric Montana
I do like to think that it was named or
destroyed the ship engine everything
yeah it's just like bugging him Sarah
Thomas Tommy okay very delicious
Victor
get ready Walter Xavier I'm just changed
my syllables
Albert Bertha he's going back through it
again the alphabet Christine Jacob Smith
Jacob Smith Elijah I think Neymar will
only appear in A Fantastic Four movie I
mean that does seem yeah
movie or an Avengers level movie since
he only cares about the safety of his
people so someone trying to wipe away
the whole universe that's never had to
make sense that's the only way to get
him out of the ocean is to be like
threatened I feel like the New World
Order though is a pretty indicative
Channel I agree that I think Captain
America which does come before Fantastic
Four uh I do think there's gonna be
something that's a global in scope yeah
there's gonna be something big does
Neymar like climate change because it's
making the oceans bigger you think he's
a fan of it because it's so hot the
water oh he's investing in like fossil
fuel candidates he's like you got to
keep doing this
are microplastics affecting the Tallow
who cares yeah that's what I mean yes he
still cares but like he kind of wants
though he's not like right like on
whatever terrorist like poison ivy is
but
terrorists but I think he's still he's
like can we just get the oceans up high
enough so that I can swim into Macy's to
get some new clothes yeah yeah longer
that's right I'll be honest I've always
wanted a home in Miami
make the shores right
you could make a middle of Kansas Miami
that's true like or Oklahoma or as I
call it America's heart oh that's right
that's very sweet no it's not right in
the center but that's okay
every time I have a heart attack I get
punched right because you have an animal
yeah
he has an elephant Heart by the way
everybody else is hard beat like this
right
okay now we did our Super Chat threshold
why don't we do our picks okay where we
think we'll see many more next okay and
we'll hit them with one of these ancient
Scrolls great Scrolls man it is hard to
say it is Scrolls Scrolls because your
emphasis on the bagels
Caribbean all right now uh I I said
Captain America new world order so
that's your favorite keeping my claim
that's what you think we'll see tonight
what about you Jessica I think
Thunderbolts but I think I don't think
it's gonna be seeing him I think it's
gonna be mentioning him a lot you think
I'm talking about him the only reason I
didn't say New World Order is there's so
many hands in the pot of new world order
that I was like if you just add this man
it's just gonna add too much yeah they
did throw a lot of extra characters
we're bringing the leader back for this
and it's like do we really need him in
this movie what's going on you know for
the sake of the Invaders which I really
dig and I love the Captain America
Throwbacks Ray has to reluctantly team
up with Namor and and there's an
iconography of like world War II Namor
that we'll never see I do think Captain
America I'm gonna go okay as well okay I
just see the episode I'm so sorry I mean
we called the internet you know to knock
where it has been very much like I don't
know what's next I'm not gonna probably
never act in an MC movie yeah they they
burned my contracts they they changed
the key code they gave me the shells
they paid me in shells I paid me and
sand dollars Thunderbolts will be a
bigger part but I think Captain America
either post-credit or something I didn't
say come back and beat mine to death no
no I think he's in it as well I'm saying
you're right as well I think I think
Neymar's gonna be a pretty good I like
your idea stinks specifically you stink
I do no I like I have a shower today I
like the idea of seeing him in Iron
Hearts only for the like through line of
like I still want to kill this girl yeah
uh maybe this is a I don't know if this
is a cop-out but like Deadpool might be
oh yeah just because if there's a mutant
story there and like waits like I want
to check in on all the mutants in the
MCU so far what two what I do say this I
I will say this I I believe this is also
a cop-out for me I do believe we will
see talokins before we've seen the more
again I believe we will soon to Logan's
uh they work for scales
yeah that's an actor joke you're not
laughing at it did you did I hear the
joke no I did I didn't think it was
funny they they they they are
represented by Ray Gents
let me finish they're represented by
Radiance and clamager
that was good Archibald bunker in the
comic saying Thunderbolts is gonna be
versus Neymar so there's a planet mookie
in the comments saying Neymar versus
Hercules would be a good fight is it on
land is it in the water because if it's
in the water I pick me more
Jacob Smith saying eternals too
Jacob Smith yay what's the number is
that that new math I've heard so much
about eternals two equals Fantastic Four
an edge Edge slice saying July 4th
special presentation of the Invaders
during World War II I mean if they don't
make a special presentation of like the
howling command yes or like capping the
boys if I have to they did hello
good horrible porn parody
Tommy
I could I mean they're not my songs
all right uh this one's kind of a deep
gun take me a while to figure out what
song it was it's actually our song it's
on groups okay okay
find it
I was swimming real deep feeling like a
real freak with a guy from Tallow God
one he we had one hand field on a
humpback wheel the others on my heart a
look around made a funny whale song He
said baby is something wrong I said
nothing I was just thinking we don't
know how long till we see you again
Neymar is in Fantastic Four messing up
plants trying to bang shoe store teasing
band and making Johnny feel real mad
well re Richards wonders why his wife's
down bad many more will start out me but
pretty soon we will see him on the right
team and when he shows up at the very
end Doctor Doom will wish he was Everett
Ross again oh that was beautiful thank
you great fine great fine thank you
thank you yeah yeah Bernard mukai Bucky
Barnes ATL the MJ 2997 film juice
knick-knack David Z Chrissy you caprita
Gabriel Martinez GSU Eagle 117 Brock
Humphreys Matthew Nunya
and Christian unpronounceable
thank you for all our super Chatters
thank you to all of our super Chatters
and you know what else I'm thankful for
we're about to get into or what I'm
thankful we're about to get into our
final round of the ink box tattoo
contest oh yeah as I call them tattoos
the two but first we want to thank
aspiration for sponsoring the show today
when it comes to climate action oh God
you're not here to change the camera
when it comes
with aspiration a new kind of change is
in your pocket simply by moving your
money to aspiration you're giving your
deposits a cleaner Greener home
aspiration is climate friendly
alternative is a climate-friendly
alternative for your money aspiration
lets you plant a tree by rounding up
every swipe of your debit card
aspiration has already funded the
planting of over 100 million trees and
they're on their way to find funding the
planting of one billion by 2030. best of
all there's no credit check thank God
you've got my attention now
no overdraft fees now you've got my
interest and with aspiration you just
what are you looking for
this guy's got his hand on my face this
guy's got his hand on my pants
best of all there's no credit check no
overdraft fees and with aspiration you
pay for what you think is fair even if
that's zero and if you're the type of
person that think it's fair to pay zero
I don't want to hang out with you
because money shouldn't stand in the way
of doing the right thing get in deep
buddy
whoa your dollars make a difference open
an aspiration account at aspiration.com
tree help save the planet with your
aspiration debit card open your account
at aspiration.com tree today
aspiration.com
to two billion dollars per depositor
beautiful Tommy as Tommy mentioned we
are on day three of the ink box to two
vote what are ink box tattoos you might
be asking if you're just tuning in for
the first time today well ink box
tattoos last one to two weeks so you can
express without worrying about whether
or not you'll want the tattoo forever
forever forever there are over ten
thousand tattoo designs to choose from
including a wide variety of sizes and
styles what we're most interested in
here at the break room is their custom
platform that lets you create your
totally unique tattoo easily we've made
a few especially for the break room all
right right now we're gonna hold our
vote
this is how it works you're gonna vote
for who you want to get the tattoo is it
going to be Tommy or is it gonna be Zach
this is day three of voting in our best
of three voting tournament so whoever
wins the vote today we'll be getting
your tattoo
okay so whose body is it going to be on
well that's the word we'll get a Gucci
to mooch a Gucci to moochie in the Harry
Potter I love this tattoo I can't wait
and then Tommy will be forced to get a
it's more of a Time Tattoo okay now hear
me out if you find a way to make it 50
50 we'll both get them
perfectly landed folks Talk Amongst
yourselves
get on the Discord figure it out
because Brandon brandor now I like the
ink box tattoos because if you're like
me you got a few ladies not just one and
they're constantly asking you to make
something permanent on your body as a
tribute to them I can get a little
two-week holler at Claire Denise Vanessa
Rebecca Trina a little bit of Monica on
my chest a little bit of Rachel on my
ass oh boy that song specifically has my
name and I was waiting for it a little
bit of Jessica on my dick hey here's the
countdown of the week hey anyways watch
it he's on probation I know they were
suspended from doing this thing uh to
get your own ink box tattoos click the
link in the video description or head to
inkbox.com and use code new rock stars
with an S to get 25 off your entire ink
box order there's no minimum order here
but you can only use this code once so
stock up look at the site the code's
good through the end of 2022 so do it
this year but like if you use that code
new rockstars get 25 off your whole
ornament I'm hearing you I have
different emails okay
get a bunch of recorders
most of the time that tattoo just says
Jess
you know why
again they last for like a couple weeks
it's great and then they come right off
very easily but so this will be on
either Zachary Tommy for Thanksgiving
probably and they both have to sit
shirtless at the Thanksgiving oh God
that's true it looks like Zach has run
away with this oh
that was a Zach wave he won by over 21
percentage points the country has spoken
yeah they and I don't blame them if
we're gonna expose someone's bare torso
on this show and we've seen mine enough
okay it's a holiday season there might
be kids watching let's show them
you also won too because you created you
coined this I did you get to put it on
him and I have everything when she's
permanently tattooed in a place in my
body I can't show on TV my throat now is
this happening on air when is this
happening uh we'll we'll do this
tomorrow we'll talk okay 24 hours yeah
so we'll put it on tomorrow I'm so
excited and we'll give the final reveal
on Friday I might get one too I know you
guys voted but God dang it I just like
tattoos okay you know what else I like
Batman the audio Adventures are crying
out loud I've been telling you for weeks
now shouting it from the mountains the
second season of the hit DC show Batman
DC's Batman the audio Adventures is out
on HBO Max I get it it's a podcast
honest remake service it's fun they put
it up on the Batcave little TV thing
they're the squiggle lines it's a fun
graphic to look at while you're
listening I just I it relaxes me despite
the violence in the show incredible cast
Rosario Dawson heard of her John
Leguizamo heard of him Bobby Moynihan
heard of him Chris Parnell never heard
of him second I'm just kidding I have
Seth Meyers Keenan Thompson and Jeffrey
Wright with the glow up of the century
going from Chris or have grown from
Commissioner Gordon to the Batman
himself an incredible show full of crime
humor in Batman lore the whole season
one is already available and season two
is out now on HBO max if you love SNL
and you love Batman combine them
together and stream DC's Batman the
audio Adventure season two out now on
HBO Max take it to the max not their
slogan it's time for mandatory fun hit
my grandfather oh my gosh tell me you
really got through that you know what
incredible I'm way more professional now
I'm a year older I'm a year wiser I'm a
year more professional a lot of the Old
Tommy B Tendencies hit the graphic
Island there are gone you did and now
they're back this is mandatory fun the
segment where I gather three of my
absolute best friends in the whole wide
world and we sit down and chop it up in
a fun way and they can't leave even if
they want because I put bombs in their
butts what wait what
according to variety Margot Robbie says
her female lead Pirates of the Caribbean
movie it is dead Pirates of the
Caribbean is okay wait did you say she
had a bomb butt yeah she does have you
seen her she's gonna bomb everything uh
now it's dead at Disney
it's not happening it's wrong no Pirates
of the Caribbean movie it's finito the
smarties okay it's more
all right it's dead it's Batgirl okay
they got us thinking about franchises
and how they should proceed you know
what Pirates of the Caribbean presumably
that movie's dead because another
movie's coming back like a certain actor
from that franchise it seems to be a
slight publicist uh win in his uh legal
issues and maybe coming back as a
titular character soon in my opinion
yeah
we all know the game f very kill um the
F stands for freak
but I made a new game up okay that's
right this game is called reboot sequel
kill okay I'm gonna give you a franchise
and you got I'm gonna pull it out of
this cup right here Harley Quinn cup
okay Mr J and I want each of you to make
a decision would you reboot this
franchise or would you make a sequel to
it if you want to do either of those I
want you to give me the log line okay
give me give me the two sentence Spiel
if it's a kill I want you to explain why
okay no I know I wrote those in the
prompter but ignore them because we're
gonna cup with them all written down
first one Ghostbusters what are we doing
with Ghostbusters so let's go back out
so I remember what it is reboot kill
sequel yeah yeah so you can either
reboot Ghostbusters you can make it a
sequel to Ghostbusters afterlife would
presumably be the fair thing or you can
kill it we're done they stuck The
Landing I don't need to see it anymore
I say kill it yeah you've gotten three
different versions of it might as well
not do a fourth right and each no well I
guess two have gotten at least two right
I personally like the new afterlife so I
so I am saying kill because I didn't
think it stuck to land yeah because I I
feel like you honored Ivan Reitman you
had Jason Redman take over his dad's
franchise we unfortunately lost Ivan
Reitman soon after right and it feels
like as much as I love the new cast as
much as I loved what they were going
towards seeing those characters for the
last time kind of worked for me yeah so
I'm gonna go kill him Winston buying the
firehouse great great great bookends
what do you need I'm gonna say kill kill
but I would also like
to reboot a animated version I was born
in 2002 I'm a young man but I've heard
about the real Ghostbusters I have
fabulous news for you Ghostbusters Day
this year they announced uh both a
reboot of the animated series and
animated films and also live action
sequel to Ghostbusters so you're all
wrong the answer was sequel hooray
this one's a little while the vacation
movies oh the Chevy Chase D'Angelo uh
D'Angelo Angela
D'Angelo Russell the Minnesota
Timberwolves shooting gun
s
they still do the shower scene from
European Vacation yeah all right we're
moving on immediately there's no way
okay perfect this one
Skywalker Saga kill right we're all
killing it right yeah I don't need it
I've said so much Skywalker and Andor is
fantastic
all right next one
Pirates of the Caribbean okay what do we
do now
this is so tough this is really tough
because I like I love the original
trilogy yeah those first three they're
bloated in this crazy
but as like if you sit down this
Thanksgiving and just watch those three
it is like what a type Fest the
gorbinsky soundtrack is incredible like
it's just so good they're great
four was a mess five was kind of fun
again yeah the problem I have with them
is is the like the way uh uh Jack
Sparrow is like god-like yeah he has
like powers in a weird way it's too much
uh Calypso that's four because I like
that one I let that one slide I know I
let that one slide just I know I like
parts of it I love what I love about the
Paris franchise is how they use
everything we know about pirates in
every way literally
the pieces of it
I say reboot this and you know who would
be a great Captain Jack Sparrow Timothy
shallow me just kidding I'm just joking
he just takes it should be a Finn
wolfhard come on he's a kooky little
coconut and now that we killed
Ghostbusters put him in here yeah he's
got free time
uh all right now I don't know why he has
that voice I want to point out something
it's 350. okay okay have you liked this
video yet do you like me no probably not
but you like Brandon Cory and Jessica so
like the video
we got two more songs here from the
whales dork okay so where is it again
you went through a lot hit
get us to 225 we'll sing both songs whoa
raise 100 more dollars I'm giving you
I'm slashing the prices of songs get us
to 225 I'll give you both songs trust me
you've heard brand new songs they're
always way better than mine you like
what you heard you're gonna get a
Brandon special and then I wrote some
other thing too they get us a 300
Brandon said he'll show his butt what
yeah
Thomas yeah no he'll spread cheeks all
right let's go I was born without a
crack oh that's right oh wow that's so
sad but also I'm interested in seeing it
now all right Jurassic Park hard reboot
I think the potential for Jurassic Park
is so strong I think that the this most
recent Trilogy when you really look at
it what what a what a fall from grace
they all made so much money so the
potential is there people still love
dinosaurs they made money not because
they were movies they made money because
they were dinosaurs like there is no
reason those movies made a billion
dollars right and I like most things
yeah and like I still had fun in them
because I was able to go huh dinosaurs
like I was able to beat five again but I
do think it'd be cleaner if you go back
to the core of what Michael Crichton
made which was a commentary on humans
always pushing things too far on life uh
finding a way I want to go back to what
the essence of the first one was and you
can't do that if you keep with
continuity okay as long as no other
dinosaur movie comes through I say
reboot because that's the thing is like
yeah what was the fun about it is
dinosaurs I love dinosaurs
I I'd say hard reboot and I have one
stipulation John Hammond
Hammond Hammond played by Jeff Goldblum
all right uh go ahead kill it kill it
whoa so much money all right I know
what's the franchise Dinosaurs
the problem is you got a park you got
done so first movie
it's the whole story and like the more
you go like it just doesn't make sense I
they did it walk away all right find a
new dinosaur movie what a flavor I'll
wear backpack
a revisiting of the classic Michael
Crichton novel John Hammond this time
event invites uh brilliant
paleontologists to his Fantasy Land of
dinosaurs reborn only for chaos to ensue
in 3D
my log line is uh the dinosaurs sex
dinosaur sex
[Music]
have you ever seen a pterodactyl fully
penetrated T-Rex you willing this one I
didn't say all that am I Jurassic pork
Jurassic Park life uh refound away wow
my reboot takes place hundreds of years
in the future where the dinosaurs have
fully taken over the Earth and they
start a park that uh brings man back
from the dead
little dinosaur children be like Mommy
the man's loose
that's Triceratops just takes a huge
dump all right now last one final one
best one
Mean Girls we've had so many
rumors about where this franchise is
going they had a great director attached
they had Tarantino writing a script for
a while here we go what's next
for boldly going where no man is gone
before on the Silver Screen I get that
they their day I got a good TV thing or
stop what's happening I'm muted
everything I just got a new Apple watch
I've lost two apple watches in the last
calendar year I got a fresh one for my
birthday shout out to my mom and I
silenced everything and this damn Apple
watch is chiming like Big Ben on the
hour and I need it I need to stand up I
need it to stop it's coming to stand up
it's telling me to work out it's telling
me to call my ex-girlfriend and make
things right it's telling me to sign my
divorce papers it's telling me to pay
child support and I don't know whoa wait
a minute Star Trek
where are we going I think the problem
with Star Trek here's the problem with
Star Trek the show and the movies have
to be two different things and they have
not found when they make a movie that is
it's called the show it's not fun right
right yeah that is an issue the Kelvin
universe doesn't feel like the show but
that is why I think it was strong for us
because they'll show about or a movie
about
Space Explorers peacefully exploring and
signing treaties and applying a code
like it's not fun entertaining big
budget action movies so I don't know if
people want that if they want that
that's not what Star Trek is to real
star it's like you can't appease
everyone in the Star Trek video I don't
know who you can appease do we want to
reboot or do you want a sequel daschal's
favorite thing in the world is Star Trek
he knows everything about it I didn't
know that oh he doesn't even want it he
doesn't even want it he doesn't want to
say that he doesn't want it just watch
wrathicon again you know what one thing
I've always known to be true you can't
can a coconut but you can canopies let's
keep going that's the end of mandatory
funds hit the graphic again
hit the Thirsty thespians graphic
it's so cool
it's so gross somebody you know you know
once again someone nefarious behind the
scenes and I'm gonna say definitely John
271
oh whoa what happened holy schmote who
was this teeny Johnson Aaron storm
coming in hot wow Jones wants a Star
Trek show and he just green lit It Tina
John says Star Trek for the win he
doesn't see what he wants to reboot it
or sequel to anything but he doesn't
have much shout out to him for letting
us know that the super chats have oh
John I effed up don't call her never
mind
for not letting us know and then I'm
trying to apologize on our Google doc
and advancing wherever you are I hope
the quiz Master finds you it makes you a
tone for your sins now
Brandon would you like to sing your song
yeah yeah I'm trying to remember the
Cadence of the song the blank spaces uh
no this was uh uh trouble trouble
oh wait I know how the chorus I'll get
there I'll get there I'll get there okay
so this was this came out of a whales
dorkus or a dork yeah dork uh uh and
this is about no more to the tune of
trouble I believe it's trouble
parentheses when you walked in here I
knew you were talking yeah but this is
when you watch it I don't know Taylor
Swift who reads track towels anyway okay
I live in the sea and you live on the
land I watched on the shore you with
that stretchy man please love me please
love me please please love me please
love me please love me
I guess you didn't care about my tight
green trunks I can promise it down there
that nothing has been shrunk believe me
believe me believe me
come to my home down in the sea you
realize that you do love me cause your
beef blow wind bubbles when you swim in
oh love please do storm grab a dolphin
when you dive in or take the water tube
because you'll be blowing bubbles when
you swim in break up with read now going
through oceans that you never swim in
and now I'm lying and on the hard drive
fan
bubbles bubbles bubbles that's good
[Applause]
bubbles bubbles all I can remember was
the goats
sorry I'm sorry Swifty's my my uh
Cadence was not great that was fine
now this song uh I think you should know
what it is uh We've again this was the
last thing this kind of went out of the
door okay right on the door
I live on the lake
I can fly for goodness sake
at least that's what people say if
established people say
I killed too many queens
I'm acting sort of mean
at least that's what people say
that's what people say
but I keep swimming my anger is brimming
it's like I got this rage always on my
mind saying destroy a mankind the
wakanda's gonna play play play play play
play U.S gonna take take take but I'm
just gonna say say say
do Miss Ross Doom is Ross
by the way uh I take away the jeers from
Anna and I send the jeers to John for
not including Top Gun in the movie
sequels uh uh reboot sequel kill we will
be doing an in-depth one hour episode on
the top one Cinematic Universe tomorrow
uh or I won't be on the show there's an
important update on the uh
I'm Brandon's ass I'm not even in good
jeans yeah yeah well you're taking them
off baby just show them the silhouette
hey guys if we raise three thousand
dollars by Friday Brandon and I will
both show around no we can't do it don't
you want quad cheeks
some of these cheeks ain't not like the
other just guess out of here before Oh
my god oh you guys thanks for tuning in
today join us here tomorrow at the same
time be sure to like And subscribe if
you haven't maybe if you like And
subscribe you get a little Brandon's
booty uh we have a ton we've been
promised so much hey I watch these they
want to see the butt we have a ton of
great videos coming out tomorrow
including my own Deep dive into what
movie Williams will be up to next uh in
ironheart inside Marvel asking questions
that you guys have clearly been asking
you asked one today yeah uh who the [ __ ]
is rere's Mystery professor
and I hear all of you thank you for all
of your kind tweets uh asking me about
uh Wikileaks and Andor Eric is handling
it from here guys I trust him he may
include me in some of his breakdowns he
may not maybe you'll never hear me talk
about Android again no we'll talk about
it all right but it's the best show on
TV and it's going to be on Hulu and all
those other channels
it's not making me feel about it all
right God he's gonna do it
[Music]